did Disney just con sag aftera and
actually get everything it wanted in
regards to AI virtually no pun intended
welcome to SRE your SciFi TV and Movie
[Music]
Channel so today sag aftera has released
a load more detail about the deal that
it has with the studios and really the
bit about AI goes on and on and on there
are so many variables it's fair to say
it's incredibly complicated now I
actually told you a few weeks ago a lot
of the other Studios Disney aside were
not that bothered about AI there was a
deal basically in principle a while ago
that set out a very simple legal
framework that covered the use of
artificial intelligence and basically
replicating in somebody's image using
that technology to replicate a voice
replicate a recognizable digital copy of
somebody and using it in movies and
cartoons and
whatever that deal basically said that
look if we're going to use something
that's recognizable as you you have to
consent and we will pay you as simple as
that it was not massively complicated it
was not massively convoluted so why have
they been arguing about it for months
well Disney was holding on to every
scrap of use of AI that it could why
because it's been spending massive
amounts of money on using digital
technology to replicate people for ages
we've seen that in Star Wars for example
where they made a young Luke in the
second series of Mandalorian where we
first saw the young Luke Skywalker it
was very plasticin and to be honest
reminded me of The Polar Express his
mouth was all weird and the eyes weren't
right but by the next time we saw young
Luke Skywalker the technology had
already progressed just in that year and
it was much much better occasionally you
could kind of tell it wasn't quite right
but on the whole it wasn't bad and
remembering that that was a TV
budget not a big cinematic movie you go
on to Indiana Jones where they created a
digital version of Harrison Ford as a
younger man and it worked pretty well so
the technology is progressing quickly
and really is only limited by how much
money you're willing to spend on it and
Disney have been really spending money
so what are the areas that they really
wanted to pin down and get a little bit
more from sag aftera than they were
willing to offer well we have this new
deal and it basically splits up the use
of digital technology into three
specific areas employment based use of
this technology independently created
digital
replicas and background workers so we'll
cover the background stuff first
actually I think sagaa did get a really
good deal on this because basically
they've done the same thing with all
three of these sections that anytime
that this technology is used it has to
be consensual so basically the studio
has to tell you before you sign the
contract exactly why they're going to
use this digital replica of you and
basically you have to give them
permission the wording is very fluffy in
a few places it basically says that the
studio has to give you a reasonable
description of what that is going to be
used for but then there is one very
interesting line in each one of these
three sections and it does say once
permission is granted even after you die
that permission continues unless
specifically says not to so basically
what that means is they can continue to
use that image for as long as they like
unless something in the contract
specifically says they can't so even
when you die they get to use that image
in the way that you agreed now that
doesn't sound too bad does it because if
you agree to do something then fine but
how about if you're a struggling actor
how about if you don't really understand
the contract that you're signing what if
you're basically just willing to sign
anything because you're just desperate
for a job then all of a sudden even
after you're dead that contract stays
legal under this agreement now the main
thing with the background actors is that
it's basically said that you can use a
background actor for this this and this
as long as it's agreed you do not have
to pay them extra if you use this for
tiling and that's basically when they
take say a 100 actors and they
superimposed boom boom boom boom boom
over top of each other over and over
again and make it look like a 100,000
people and they do this a lot in battle
scenes they've been doing it for years
but what it does say interestingly is
that if an actor's background image if
the contract basically is specifically
for a background use and then is
digitally manipulated to make it either
look like or to actually say words
it cannot be used as a background image
anymore it actually then clicks into one
of the other two categories as a
basically a working actor rather than
just somebody in the
background so what are the other two
employment-based the use of digital
technology within a specific contract so
now this is you're an actor you're star
in a movie they take a digital scan of
view and they can then basically do
stuff with it for example make make you
look younger make you look older make
you be able to do triple back flips
whatever now that is basically just
using CGI computer generated imagery
like we've been doing for a few years
now for example if you're Tom Holland
and you're in the next Spider-Man movie
there are certain things that Spider-Man
can do that you can't and they need to
use CGI now when they're going to be
doing this with the use of AI in
particular particular which is like next
Generation
CGI they have to explain exactly what
that technology is going to be used for
and what the digital copy of you will
then be used for that needs to be
spelled out reasonably so again the
studio only basically has to tell you
what is reasonable I.E they do not have
to go into the manua of every single
detail of what they're going to do with
it they just need to give you the broad
Strokes that Digital Image can then not
be used for anything else an interesting
thing though is that if the digital
image is then used for something that
appears in the movie The Studio has to
figure out how many days reasonably it
would have took you the actor to film
those parts if you had been able to so
using the Spider-Man analogy Spider-Man
is swinging through the city saving
people left right and Center they decide
to do that using AI so Tom Holland is
never there the producers then have to
go but we if we had have used him on
ropes swinging through the thing and if
we' have filmed that shot how long is it
reasonable to say those shots would have
taken to film 10 days you get 10 days
pay that is how that new deal is going
to work now it's going to rely a great
deal on the producers and the
studios acting in good faith and it
actually says in the contract that they
have to act in good faith that is just a
soft way of saying we got to trust you
now I actually think a lot of Studios
with big stars will not try to faf
around with that because they do not
want to get somebody like Tom Holland
kicking off afterwards going you RI me
off by this many days and blah blah blah
or you go and watch the movie and you
suddenly as an actor realize I'm only in
like 10 minutes this film the rest of it
isn't me and kicking off but how many of
the smaller actors will they do that to
and how many will they just go ah three
days that'll do at the end of the day if
you underestimate enough once you've
done that enough times you start to make
a really big saving as a studio I
actually had this once when I was in a
job I was um basically being paid by the
hour and then years later I bumped into
my old manager and he's chatting away
and he's having a laugh and he's say he
saying that what I used to do was if
anybody ever used to work like an hour
and five minutes I just used to round it
down and oh God the bosses loved me
because I was saving like 10% on the
wages income basically and I sat there
going
you've forgotten I used to work for you
how many times did you round down my
hours how much did you cost to me over
the two or three years I work for you
that is going to be at least a
Temptation for Studios to round things
down a little bit to save money again
permission for any of these projects and
any of these contracts continues after
death so if you sign something to say
that you can use my digital image in the
sequel or the SQL sequel or blah blah
blah and you kind of have to opt out of
that so you have to say something
explicitly for when the permission ends
or it goes on forever now to be honest
that's a relatively realistic and
reasonable legal thing to do because
particularly under this employment based
this contract would only actually be
related to one production I.E one movie
so that doesn't really mean anything
because once Film It Ends permission
technically ends too the reason reason
why I mention it though is because of
the legales of that is added for a
specific reason to create loopholes and
this is what Disney were trying to do
but there's one area in specific they've
created a massive loophole something
that they fought really hard for and
something Saga did not want to give them
re-shoot there is a massive section in
this an exemption for post production
now this is actually more to do with the
next section an independently created
digital replica and that basically means
digitally they create an electronic
version of you or your voice they don't
necessarily have to scan you you don't
necessarily have to be there for them to
take the measurements or to create that
replica it is a digital creation of you
now again you're an actor you're in a
big movie they get to the end of the
film and they realize oh there's a
continuity area you're wearing the wrong
thing in your shirt or something in the
olden days they would have to get you
back pay you for a couple of days work
and do the re-shoot to fix the problem
now this deal specifically says they
don't have to do that now to a degree I
would understand that if it's a small
error a small problem they would just
fix it using CGI but this goes on to say
significantly more so post production
sound wardrobe pitch continuity
adjusting dialogue or actual storyline
or any other related effect so basically
that very Loosely says any type of
re-shoot they want to do if they can do
it without getting the actors back they
will now why is that happening because
Studios particularly Disney have been
spending a lot of money on the way they
produce movies and by this I mean
they've been planning for quite a while
to eliminate the need for re-shoot
because re-shoot are massively expensive
so what happens normally you do a film
say the new Avengers movie and then you
show it to a bunch of people and they
don't like it or Executives go oh God I
don't like this I don't like that or
maybe there's a big scandal with one of
the actors and you want to remove them
or rewrite the story so that it doesn't
basically create a load of problems you
have to then bring those actors back at
normally massive expense even though it
would be contracted in so they kind of
don't have a choice but worse you might
have to build
sets higher back Lots go back out to
anywhere that they filmed previously I
I.E say if you filmed on a street
somewhere you then have to go get
permits to do it again over and over
again there are a million little
problems with this and a million little
expenses
it does sometimes add 10 20 30 million
dollar onto the cost of a movie or more
but what Disney have been trying to do
is planning ahead during production they
have not doing a re-shoot in mind so
that they can digitally change
everything so they will use more cameras
than necessary and things like this in
order to be able to then go to the 3D
imaging at the end and basically the CGI
guy goes right I can just change it the
idea being that they will never need to
do re-shoot again even if they change
significant parts of the dialogue now
that is mad and it basically means an
entire tone of a movie could be changed
how important is certain lines how
important is certain actions within a
movie you could be an actor you could
agree to a script and do a movie and
think you're the good guy and by the end
of it through this digital manipulation
they could completely change your
character and there is nothing you could
do about it again I don't think this is
going to affect the big A-list actors
all that much but the 95% of the other
actors I'd be a little concerned and
this is only really going to be relevant
to motion pictures for now but to be
honest TV series are getting such high
quality now and having such big budgets
that really the big budget TV shows are
film level quality so it's going to be
affecting them too Disney really fought
for this one provision and it really
does give them almost free reign to do
in post production whatever they want
and if I'm
honest from a production point of view I
can 100% see why the studios would want
to do this and apparently Warner
Brothers are on board with this as well
it's the only reason that Disney got it
through because they got some allies
within the studios to support
them at end to day it makes their life
much much easier and if you have just a
continuity error it should be easily
brushed up and fixed using CGI why not
why would you go through the expense of
the actors dragging them back and the
cost the actors probably wouldn't want
to do it anyway they're going to drag me
back to LA for one day because I was
wearing the wrong color tie come on but
when you're changing dialogue when
you're changing the entire theme of a
scene I think that's a little different
generally speaking when you're digitally
altering a performance you need to get
consent except if it's in post-
production which most scenes if they
alter will be even though the contract
repeatedly says you need to get consent
it then says it has this exemption and
my point is it creates a loophole it
creates very legal definitions that
allow them to make certain
alterations and never have to get
consent for It Disney have been very
clever with this and I tell you what
reading the document I had to get
somebody with a legal background to
explain several elements of it to me
because as my dad would say it reads
like DVD
instructions it reads like the
instructions you get when you're
installing a new printer way too many
words and all you want is a
straightforward what can I do and when
this document does not do that it is I
am told purposefully convoluted
purposefully complicated and it really
is going to require an awful lot of
effort from Studios and agents Etc to
really understand what they owe to the
actors and when
I asked my source have the Actors Guild
I asked my source Saga for Bond he said
well yes and no obviously this contract
was going to be complicated anyway
because every contract ever is but he
says he can see several ways the studios
can get around paying people when sagra
think they're going to get paid because
at the end of the day if a studio
behaves in good faith and follow this
agreement in its Spirit of the rules
then they shouldn't have a problem but
if a studio and I'm looking at Disney
decides to follow many of these rules to
the absolute letter and to be very
specific about the way they use certain
elements of this contract then a lot of
actors could get out of being paid a lot
of money and to be honest the way the
subscription deal for subscribers to
contribute towards a fund for sagra is
written in a very similar way and I've
also been told sagaa might not get
anything like the money they think
they're going to get this to me sounds
an awful lot like in three years time
we're going to be having the same
arguments I just really hope the studios
at least go into the spirit of the deal
and then hopefully we won't have more
strikes but let's see at the end of the
day this whole thing with AI is a hot
mess it's very confusing what is AI what
is CGI what is it's complicated the
studios try to have a simplified deal a
few years ago knowing that the courts
might change all this anyway if an actor
decides to sue a studio and wins it
would create precedent and could throw
this contract out of the window in a
second so they wanted something simple
I'm talking about the small Studios now
but Disney want to use they massive
investment in AI for as long as
possible it's not necessarily a good
thing for most of the actors out
there but get into the coms and tell me
what you think do these rules make sense
to you have you actually read them
there's a link in the description to the
deadline story which tells you the whole
thing and honestly go through each
section of the AI rules in particular if
you can understand most of it you're a
better man than me and do you actually
agree with me that the chances are in
three years time we're going to be back
having the same argument I hope not but
it feels like it get into the comments
and tell me exactly what you think if
you are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification do
all the buttony things it really helps
us out and you'll never miss any of our
new videos also go to patreon.com sidre
where most of our new videos Premier
first and you get to see them without
the adverts for a small contribution
each month that really supports the
channel also go toy Che .co.uk which is
our dedicated website where we do
articles based on most of our stories
and we try to add a little bit more
information for you to digest as always
please stay safe and I'll see you next
[Music]
time